question numéro 83 de monsieur philippe
dominati à monsieur le ministre chargé
des transports de la paire de la pêche
et de la mer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
par cette question attirer à nouveau
l'attention du gouvernement sur
l'aménagement ou le réaménagement des
voies sur berge au coeur de notre
capitale
cela concerne aussi bien la rive gauche
que la rive droite sur la rive droite il
s'agit d'un aménagement qui a été fait
qui consiste à couper le flux de
circulation sur la rive gauche il s'agit
ni plus ni moins de la fermeture des
voies sur berges des voix qui voyait un
trafic automobile de l'ordre de 4000
véhicules par heure trente mille
véhicules par jour enfin tous les
parisiens où tous ceux qui sont
concernés par l'activité économique de
la capitale connaissent ces chiffres on
sait que la motivation de cet
aménagement aussi été fait pour des
raisons de l'aménagement de bien-être et
d'écologie au ritz homme s'aperçoit à la
pratique que nous enregistrons
actuellement des pics de pollution
depuis la mise en place de ce
réaménagement des parisiens d'ailleurs
leur part sondages se sont exprimés à
plusieurs reprises en étant hostiles
dans des chiffres variant entre 70 et
80% monsieur le ministre deuxièmement
qu'ils payent l'utilisation ou
l'aménagement des voies sur berge c'est
l'effort unique de la municipalité alors
qu'elles sont utilisés en grande partie
j'dirais par le citoyen et le citoyen
franciliens c'est du domaine normalement
de la région je suis partisan d'un
aménagement des voies sur berge d'un
aménagement du fleuve comme dans toutes
les grandes capitales européennes où
dans toutes les villes françaises qui
sont en proximité d'un fleuve il n'est
pas naturel bien évidemment de conserver
l'infrastructure routière qu'il y avait
à peu près il ya un demi siècle pour
autant il faut le faire je dirais en
concertation il faut le faire en
intelligence la concertation n'a pas eu
lieu euh ya une volonté une volonté qui
a été exprimé par le maire de paris et
le gouvernement précédent compte tenu de
l'insuffisance des études d'impact
avaient purement reportés et annulés
c'est votre gouvernement vos gouvernants
seul qui a autorisé ou sollicitées
l'aménagement de ces voies sur berge
pour autant je suis ravie monsieur
meunier ce que vous soyez là à plusieurs
reprises je vous ai interrogé sur des
affaires concernant le grand paris mais
il est vrai que c'est un domaine où
parfois c'est le premier ministre qui
veut agir au nom du grand paris de la
restructuration parfois ce ministre des
finances qui sur la taxe spéciale
d'équipement et là en réalité je
m'attendais à voir le ministre de
l'intérieur parce que paris est une
ville particulière où les pouvoirs de
police du maire et vous vous avez été
maire je crois vous connaissez bien le
mandat municipal les pouvoirs de police
du maire à paris sont détenus non pas
par le maire de paris mais par le préfet
de police le préfet de police il ne
dépend de qui uniquement est strictement
du ministre de l'intérieur et le
ministre l'intérieur s'est exprimé
monsieur le président le 16 février dans
le journal
notre presse régionale je dirais dans un
quotidien parisien en expliquant qu'
apparemment c'était une aberration et
moi je voudrais savoir depuis le 16
février
qu'a fait le gouvernement que s'est il
passé puisque le ministre de l'intérieur
patron direct du préfet police dit c'est
une aberration la capitale est perturbé
tout le monde le constate
quotidiennement et pour autant
j'aimerais savoir où on en est voilà ma
question monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur dominati la parole est à
monsieur frédéric cuvillier mini chargé
des transports de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur merci
pour la satisfaction vous exprimer de me
voir ici présents et de pouvoir
m'interpeller sachez que c'est une
satisfaction réciproque et de pouvoir
m'exprimer sur ce thème celui de la
mobilité de de l'ambition qui est
exprimée ici à paris mais dans d'autres
agglomérations celles qui ont la chance
d'avoir un réseau fluvial de reconquête
par la ville de ces espaces notamment
des berges des différents fleuves paris
est de ce point de vue une
ils m'ont dial mans connu bien
évidemment mais reconnu pour son enjeu
de patrimoine pour sa réalité historique
pour sa grandeur son image et donc de ce
point de vue
effectivement il est important de
pouvoir faire concilier les différents
modes de transport c'est un objectif qui
est recherchée avec
ses modes de transport et la réalité de
l'aménagement de l'environnement urbain
finalement c'est une finalité recherchée
par les citoyens par la puissance
publique et il est important vous le
soulignez d'ailleurs dans votre
intervention il est important que la
modernisation des infrastructures
prennent en compte à la fois les usages
ils sont différents il ya même des
conflits d'usagé et l'accès facilité un
certain nombre de quartiers
sans oublier la nécessité d'avoir une
réflexion sur les transports plus
vertueux de ce point de vue le fluvial
peut-être aussi une source de
développement nous n'avons pas fini de
réinventer finalement l' usage de la
ville et les modes de transport dans la
ville la capitale et de ce point de vue
un vrai laboratoire et je tiens à saluer
les initiatives qui sont prises par sa
municipalité par son maire qui a cette
vision qui a cette ambition de redonner
toute l'ampleur toute la splendeur à
cette ville qui nous donne fierté alors
vous m'interrogez sur les aménagements
je vais pas faire le point sur
l'évolution de ce chantier la
fermeture notamment des quais bas date
du 28 janvier dernier sur la rive droite
il ya un certain nombre d'aménagements
la mise en place d'aménagements flottant
qui seront effectives dès l'ouverture du
site au public sera très attendu à
partir de juin le juin 2013 qui
permettra d'avoir une perspective
estivale agréable pour les promeneurs
les visiteurs mais également pour les
habitants de paris qui pourront
bénéficier de cet environnement
qualitatif est améliorée alors je tiens
à vous signaler puisque vous faisiez et
à des compétences les schémas
d'aménagement tout ce qui est
aménagements urbains urbanisme relève
bien évidemment de la ville de paris et
d'ailleurs les bords de seine
appartiennent au réseau de la ville de
paris et d'eau savait pas précisément
ici que vous pouvez les l'état l'état à
la charge de la réglementation notamment
la réglementation de la circulation
routière ça c'est du ressort de l'état
et la préfecture de police est dans son
rôle lorsqu'il s'agit de la
réglementation vous avez
évoqué les conséquences de ces
aménagements il y à un certain nombre de
deux d'études qui sont réalisés de
sondages de comptage effectué en temps
réel et qui indiquent qu'il y a une
faible
comment
répercussions sur
les temps de parcours de suite à
l'aménagement et à la mise en place de
ce dispositif de réaménagement des
berges de la liane de l'ordre de 1 à
l'une à 3 minutes de différence en
termes de variation de temps de parcours
je n'ai pas bien évidemment des heures
laquelle tout cela intervient sur la
pollution atmosphérique
vous avez raison puisque de souligner
que nous avons beaucoup d'efforts à
faire je rappelle d'ailleurs que la
france risque d'être condamnée en
manquement de ce point de vue puisque
nos prédécesseurs n'ont pas de vrai
n'ont pas agi et que delphine batho moi
même et l'ensemble du gouvernement sont
en train de mettre en place un véritable
dispositif pour l'amélioration de la
qualité atmosphérique de l'air qualité
de l'air au risque de ne pas répondre
aux engagements européens qui sont les
nôtres alors vous dire simplement vous
parlez d'une mutualisation des espaces
et des voiries
bien évidemment les villes centres de
les agglomérations dans les
agglomérations ont le même problème
d'une voirie qui leur appartient mais
qui est pourtant d'usagé au plus grand
nombre y compris à des habitants qui ne
sont pas précisément des habitants de la
collectivité concernée paris n'échappe
pas à cette réalité et j'allais dire
vous dites c'est un enjeu d'une voirie
régional la région n'a pas sauf si vous
amendé le texte sur la décentralisation
qui viendra à votre étude la région n'a
pas de compétence routière là pas de
domaine public routier il n'en demeure
pas moins que vous êtes même en deçà de
la vérité puisque c est une
responsabilité nationale voire même
internationale compte tenu d usagers de
ces voiries donc il appartient à la
collectivité tout simplement puisque
c'est du domaine public communal de
faire en sorte que ses ambitions ses
objectifs ses enjeux d'amélioration de
mobilisation pour redonner tout le faste
et toute la qualité de vie à
l'environnement urbain et bien soit à un
objectif partagé nul doute que dans
quelques semaines vous serez à
l'inauguration de ces aménagements nul
doute que dans quelques semaines vous
applaudirez avec le public qui sera
certainement enthousiasmés par cette
reconquête de la ville cette
transformation et cette amélioration de
la qualité de cadre de vie parisien
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
dominati
monsieur le ministre je vous ai posé une
question précise une question au
gouvernement vous me répondez par un
discours qui est peut-être la plaquette
de présentation du maire de paris vous
parlez d'une ambition qu'il a une vision
une ambition
il a l'ambition de partir à la retraite
surtout parce que ça fait onze ans qu'il
est là on sait très bien qu'il se
représente pas alors ne me parlez pas de
l'ambition du maire de paris je vous
pose une question précise vous me parlez
d'une presque un programme électoral
nous savons tous les deux être est des
hommes publics mais franchement
la région la région investit vous le
savez comme moi dans l'investissement
des infrastructures routières on couvre
le périphérique on couvre des voies
d'autoroute dans des départements
limitrophes de paris ou à 50 mètres de
notre dame on n'est pas capable d'avoir
les deux c'est à dire préserver
l'activité économique de la capitale
avec des voies rapides et de couvrir
pour avoir un aménagement ont fait un
projet à l'économie sur un petit but sur
une somme importante mais qu'il n'est
rien par rapport à l'égard des demies
deux kilomètres et demi d'un côté deux
kilomètres et demi de l'autre de
l'aménagement du fleuve l'état devrait
intervenir vous dites on n'a pas les
pouvoirs mais vous avez tout à fait les
pouvoirs puisque vous avez le pouvoir de
réglementation les pouvoirs de police du
maire c'est le préfet et si le ministre
de l'intérieur il fait une grande
déclaration le journal de paris dans
l'édition quotidienne en voyant les les
lecteurs le 16 février depuis le
gouvernement on fait quoi rien on va
participer à l'inauguration
vous me parler d'aménagement flottant de
remise en valeur de la scène il y à 11
ans 11 ans lorsque le maire de paris est
arrivé il a dit on va prendre la kz2 la
scène absolument la région aussi il ya
11 ans lorsque monsieur huchon est
arrivé on a dit on va faire la scène il
ya une société mixte qui a été fait elle
a fait faillite on est obligé la
renflouer c'était il ya un an vous le
savez très bien on est obligé de
remettre de l'argent ça fait dix ans que
le le projet capote régulièrement et
vous me parlez d'une ambition nouvelle
mais il n'ya pas que les aménagements
qui sont flottants monsieur le ministre
il ya la position du gouvernement qui
est flottante sur ce sujet et moi
j'aimerais vraiment que ça ne sert à
rien de faire semblant de critiqué dans
la presse en disant l'activité
économique est en danger à paris -
ministre de l'intérieur je dis que c'est
anormal et le membre du gouvernement dit
venez à l'inauguration vous serez ravis
non je ne suis pas ravi les parisiennes
sont pas ravis et prenez une position
ferme et intéressez vous monsieur
minispace que je vois que vous êtes
présent très souvent sur les sujets
parisien mais faîtes entendre votre voix
vous avez été un élu local ne laissait
pas faire des choses comme ça au petit
bonheur la chance et un an des élections
alors qu'on est là depuis plus de 11 ans